[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je me balade à propriété ou ailleurs
et que je pose spontanément la question
aux gens que je rencontre au tahitien
notamment aux jeunes aux plus vieux
est-ce que vous parlez tahitien
automatiquement j'ai envie de dire
qu'ils vont me répondre
quasiment de manière sûre ah non je ne
parle pas tahitien non je ne vois pas
tahitien alors effectivement quand on
commence à additionner tous ces discours
là quand on commence à additionner le
nombre de personnes qui disent qu'ils
déclarent ne pas pas les tahitiens on se
demande effectivement dit donc la
situation du tahitien est catastrophique
tout le monde toutes les personnes que
je rencontre me disent non je ne parle
pas tahitien mais en fait quand on y
réfléchit un petit peu qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
quand on dit je ne parle pas tahitien
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand quelqu'un me dit quand quelqu'un
nous dit oh non non non je ne parle pas
tahitien parce qu'effectivement par
exemple moi quand je vous dis je ne
parle pas tibétains je ne parle pas
cours et un jeu ne parlent pas chinois
que celles effectivement d'un point de
vue linguistique
je ne parle pas tibétains mais nos gens
nos jeunes moins jeunes en polynésie
française qui déclare alors qu'ils ont
vécu toute leur vie dans notre
territoire dans notre beau pays ne pas
parler tahitien effectivement que là on
n'est pas dans la même situation
linguistique que quelqu'un qui comme -
par exemple déclaré spontanément et à
juste titre que je ne parle pas
tibétains donc forcément ça veut dire
quelque chose qu'il y a quelque chose à
gratter derrière flins je vais vous
raconter une petite anecdote que j'ai
vécu il ya quelques années de cela
j'étais allé il ya quelques années
participer ou assister à la cérémonie de
la marche sur le feu qui est organisé
chaque année à l'occasion de l'ouverture
des festivités du heiva i tahiti et donc
pendant cette année là le pet qui devait
officier qui d'habitude était raymond
graffe cette année là ce n'était pas
vraiment grave qui office
iran tant que plate mais il avait mis
sans fils de 16 ans à l'époque en avant
pour justement conduire toute la
cérémonie et j'étais là en tant que
spectateur et j'étais à siéger coûté
j'écoutais ce jeune homme de 16 ans 17
ans passionné par ce qu'il faisait
conduire cette cérémonie religieuse
spirituelle
pendant deux heures dans un tahitien
impeccable impeccable et j'étais moi
même très comment dire un trio n'est pas
la qualité de santé de 200 haïtiens
évidemment il est le fils de raymond
graffe donc on se dit que c'est beaucoup
plus facile
et voilà qu'à la fin de son intervention
de sa cérémonie pardon il y a la horde
de journalistes qui se ruent vers lui
justement pour lui poser les questions
parce que là c'est le moment de poser
des questions pour le journal télévisé
et la première question en français et
effectivement dans un français
approximatif il répond à l'aise sont
complexes
la parole est libre et elle glisse
combien même d'un point de vue
grammatical ou que sais-je s'est pas
totalement correct mais peu importe il
s'exprime en français dans son français
approximatif et voilà que comme à
l'habitude une fois l'interview en
france est terminée on passe à
l'interview tahitien la waho il déclaré
aux journalistes à nos pantins anciens
je parle pas tahitien alors j'étais
assis à côté je me suis dit mais enfin
je t ai écouté j'ai été interloqué par
le fait que pendant deux heures
notre ami avait conduit une cérémonie
exclusivement tahitien que voilà une
fois devant les caméras vont sans doute
qui a la pression de la caméra etc
mais une fois devant un autre public il
déclarait ne pas parler tahitien alors
la partie de là je me suis mis à
réfléchir à réfléchir parce que
finalement cette situation là n'est
qu'un exemple parmi tant d'autres
comme je vous le disais je peux aller
partout à papeete ou ailleurs est posée
spontanément la question comme ça de but
en blanc aux personnes ou et théoriques
parle treaty est-ce que tu parles
tahitien est très généralement très
souvent les gens vont répondre non je ne
parle pas taillé c'est alors qu'est ce
que c'est
à veut dire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand quelqu'un vocalises et dit non je
ne parle pas tahitien en tant que
sociologue
on m a interprété justement ce qu'on
appelle être du sens commun
1 et donc s'il fallait que j'interprète
personnellement sociologiquement ce
propos non je ne parle pas tahitien et
bien je l'interdis très sociaux logement
la manière suivante
non je pense ne pas savoir suffisamment
maîtriser les codes de l'expression
orale en tahitien en public en public
pour me donner l'autorisation pour me
permettre de m'exprimer dans ma langue
maternelle à savoir le tahitien est donc
là ça change la donne là on n'est plus
dans un problème purement linguistique
c'est à dire moi je ne parle pas
tibétains on n'est pas dans ce cas de
figure là on est dans un cas de figure
je dirais plutôt de sociolinguistique
c'est à dire que ce qui fait que ce
jeune homme nous - inclus à une certaine
époque où je vocalises et non je parle
pas tahitien c'était parce que c'est
parce que nous sommes menus tout un
chacun par des complexes par des
complexes qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
dimension purement linguistiques
c'est un complexe sociétal un complexe
sociétal parce que effectivement par les
tahitiens ce n'est pas tout à fait comme
parler le français
un exemple quand on va au journal
télévisé sur les faux site mtv ou etc
en tout cas quand on est médiatisé d'une
certaine manière les journalistes en
tahitien après l'interview tahitien si
vous avez fait une bonne interview
évidemment ils vont souvent en tout cas
vous féliciter en disant aux ultimes été
ou de poterie tiguan tu sais si tu sais
très bien par les tahitiens alors qu'en
france est par contre en france et
jamais en tout cas pour moi ça m'est
arrivé qu'un journaliste en langue
française le congratule à la forme isa
mais dis donc steve tu t'exprimes
drôlement bien français
jamais jamais alors quand haïtien
effectivement ça se fait ça se fait
pourquoi parce que effectivement le
rapport que nous avons avec le tahitien
est différent du rapport que nous avons
avec le français en tahitien ce qui est
important c'est la performance oratoire
à partir du moment où on doit s'exprimer
en tahitien et a fortiori en public et
j'inclus les caméras à l'intérieur quand
on est en public
nous ne sommes plus dans un rapport de
communication comme on peut l'être en
france et on a un message à porter xetra
on est dans un rapport de performance en
juge la performance oratoire et c'est ça
justement qui est jugé par les
téléspectateurs par le public
à partir du moment où on entend
quelqu'un se lever et s'exprimer
publiquement tahitien et c'est là
effectivement ou les jugements tombe
aussi à tonalité de par le crédit ne
sait pas parler taille ça il ne sait pas
bien par les tahitiens il ne parle pas
assez bien tahitien parce que nous
sommes dans le rapport de la performance
et nous sommes dans ce rapport la de la
performance oratoire de la performance
linguistique
parce que aussi nous amalgamant les
statut linguistique autrement dit il y a
deux statues il ya celui le statut de
l'orateur en tahitien c'est à dire celui
qui maîtrise les codes de l'oralité en
tahitien celui qui maîtrise les
métaphores qui convient d'utiliser dans
son discours en tahitien celui qui
maîtrise le vocabulaire adapté à une
prise de parole en public en tahitien
celui qui maîtrise les normes
d'éloquence
tout ça fait partie des normes du statut
d'orateur et ce statut d'orateur
l'apprend le monopole dans notre société
prend un tel monopole dans notre société
que finalement on oublie consciemment
pas qu'il y à aussi non pas les orateurs
mais les locuteurs
quand on est locuteurs nous ne sommes
pas du coup assujettis à tout un tas de
normes d'orateur de d'expression
d'éloquence de charisme de vocabulaire
d'expressions idiomatiques et c'est un
nom n'est pas assujetti à tout cela on
est simplement dans la communication et
à partir de là quand on est dans la
communication
nous avons de ce fait une certaine
latitude par rapport à la qualité
linguistique de la langue à la maison
quand je suis chez moi avec ma famille
que je me mets à palente haïtien c'est
pas du tout la même chose quand je mets
à m'exprimer en tahitien on public
on n'est pas dans le même rapport je
suis dans le rapport du locuteur
or dans notre pays nous avons tellement
mis l'accent de par notre histoire
de par notre culture de par nos origines
nous avons mis l'accent essentiellement
sur le statut de locuteurs de pardon
excusez moi d'orateur et c'est
exactement cela
u11 des effets une des causes qui fait
que les jeunes les moins jeunes qui eux
sont dans un rapport de communication
basique en tahitien et y'a pas de mal
verbalise spontanément non je ne parle
pas tahitien je ne parle pas tahitien
parce que je me protège c'est une
stratégie d'évitement
c'est une stratégie de protection de soi
même parce qu'effectivement à partir du
moment dit oui je parle tahitien à la
tout le monde le gardian nous vient les
oreilles et là on attend une performance
oratoire et à partir du moment où cette
personne n'est pas capable de remplir ce
contrat sociolinguistique dirons-nous
pour utiliser un peu des termes
techniques et bien là à partir de là non
tu ne remplit pas le contrat tu n'es pas
dans la performance et la vienne les
critiques et la vienne les attaques et
la vienne les piques et quand les pics
les attaques arrive et caetera et
caetera et bien ça produit ce que l'on
connaît dans notre pays le mutisme le
mutisme de notre langue très souvent
également un en tant que professeur de
tahitiens ou en expert de la langue
tahitienne
on m'a souvent posé également la
question que ce soit la part des parents
de la part des élèves des étudiants ou
de n'importe qui mais steve en fin de
compte
à quoi ça sert le tahitien à quoi ça
sert de parler tahitien dans un monde
dans la mondialisation que nous
naissant à l'heure actuelle où
effectivement l'anglais et le mandarin
télé très très bientôt voit peut-être
déjà tout de suite vont devenir des
langues puissante d'un point de vue
économique dans tout le monde danse
était dans cette mondialisation
à quoi ça sert de parler tahitien eh
bien voyez-vous quand on pose de cette
question c'est à dire quand oppose à
quoi ça cesse autrement dit on pose la
question de l'utilité de la langue
tahitienne est bien dans cette question
là il faut aussi se traduire ses propos
là de manière sociologique
autrement dit à quoi ça sert de parler
tahitien traduction est ce que mon gamin
en apprenant le tahitien pourra un jour
éventuellement décrocher un job où il va
gagner 400 mille francs par mois c'est
assez triviale je sais bien je
caricature mais ça reflète quand même
une certaine réalité cachée dans les
esprits de certains qui pose la question
de l'utilité de la langue tahitienne à
quoi ça sert le tahitien traduction est
ce que mon gamin va pouvoir tout
simplement et légitimement avoir un
boulot et pouvoir vive
or quand on pose la question de
l'utilité on amalgame le concept
d'utilité avec le concept de valeur très
souvent on pense que ce qui est utile
être automatiquement a automatiquement
de la valeur du tout on est dans la
malle gamme une chaise une table à
repasser par exemple pour passer ma
belle chemise qui est un petit peu
froissé une table à repasser est
extraordinairement utile mais est-ce que
la table à repasser a de la valeur ou en
tout cas de la valeur dans ma vie en
tant que tahitien dans ma vie en tant
que polynésiens n'ont donc il faut bien
dissocier effectivement la question
d'une part de l'utilité est ce que c'est
utile et la question de la valeur or
quand les gens se base essentiellement
les parents d'élèves les élèves etc
cette élection sur la question de
l'utilité donc de sa valeur mercantile
on oublie totalement on occulte
totalement la question qui pour nous
en tout cas est essentiel des questions
de la valeur des langues vernaculaires
la valeur du lot marie
qu'en est il de sa valeur poétique
qu'en est il de sa valeur philosophique
qu'en est il de sa valeur culturelle
qu'en est il de sa valeur esthétique
qu'en est il de sa valeur identitaire
qu'en est il de sa valeur en tant que
vision d'une vision d'une certaine
vision du monde tout cela fait partie de
la valeur mais on n'y apporte pas grand
attention parce qu'effectivement nous
sommes monopolisé par l'essentiel
question de l'utilité mercantile utilité
en termes d'argent et je pense que si
nous vivons dans une société saine
si nous devons vivre dans une société
saine ou en tout cas apaisé dans nos
complexes nous devons également regarder
l'aspect de la valeur patrimoniale de
nos langues
l'aspect de la valeur esthétique
poétique philosophique de nos langues
vernaculaires ça ça compte également et
pas uniquement avoir un rapport avec les
langues vernaculaires du type est ce que
dans un calcul est ce que en choisissant
cette langue je vais pouvoir avoir un
travail qui va me rapporter temps là on
est dans une vision extraordinairement
appauvri de ce que c'est qu'une langue
et a fortiori de ce que c'est qu'une
langue autochtone dans un pays
autochtones donc réfléchissant et c'est
mon message
réfléchissant sur ses dimensions là
attention dissociant bien ce qui est du
lot de l'ordre de l'orateur de l'ordre
de ce qui est du locuteur dissociant la
performance oratoire de la performance
de la communication ce sont deux choses
à dissocier dissociant enfin dissociant
enfin le concept d'utilité au concept de
valeur
et c'est exactement pour toutes ces
raisons là et c'est exactement pour tous
ces amalgames que nous avons dans nos
têtes
moi y compris je ne suis pas un cas à
part c'est tous ces amalgames là qui
font qu'aujourd'hui nos jeunes ou moins
jeunes ont du mal à verbaliser ont du
mal à faire sortir cette langue qui est
déjà présent dans leur aaa ou dans leur
dans leurs entrailles qui l'a verbalisée
à faire sortir parce que nous sommes
onze celui c'est le mot enseveli sous
une tonne de complexes qui eux-mêmes
tirent leur énergie au travers de tous
les amalgames que nous avons dont être
par rapport aux longues
donc oui le thème de notre de notre
rencontre aujourd'hui c'est sortant de
notre zone de confort à demain pour la
langue tahitienne ou pour toutes les
autres langues polynésiennes sortant de
notre zone de confort et aux en osant
pour ceux qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
s'exprimer osez osez parce que cette
langue vous appartient tout comme m
appartient vous en êtes les héritiers et
nous qui sommes soi-disant expert de la
langue tahitienne
nous avons le devoir et la wii c'est un
devoir
nous avons le devoir d'être
bienveillants envers ceux qui font le
preuve de courage s'exprimer à sortir de
cette zone de confort et à verbaliser et
à faire sortir cette langue
nous devons faire preuve de
bienveillance de tolérance et
d'acceptation
parce que finalement les les erreurs
j'ai envie de dire quand on part faire
du shopping à los angeles et qu'on
essaie tout un chacun de baragouiner en
anglais ça nous pose aucun problème
n'est ce pas aucun problème alors là on
est fort on peut baragouiner n'importe
quoi en anglais aucun problème
on s'explique aucun complexe et c'est
pourquoi diable donc lorsqu'il s'agit de
la langue tahitien de notre langue à
nous la mutisme non sortant de notre
zone de confort et soyons bienveillant
les uns envers les autres organes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]